[Musik]
eine konferenz vor dem scheitern 196
länder ringen in madrid um das weltklima
die gräben sind weiter tief einen bon
für jedes brötchen in der
bundesregierung gibt es streit um die
neue kassenzettel pflicht die im neuen
jahr kommt und krise am schießstand die
erfolgsverwöhnten deutschen biathleten
laufen der konkurrenz hinterher
nachrichten nicht da das heute mit
christian sievers einen schönen guten
abend hinein und herzlich willkommen bei
uns heute um 7 wir fassen ihnen diesen
nachrichten tag zusammen und haben
norbert könig hier für den sport ja die
fußball profis zumindest waren
treffsicher schön genannt im kampf für
das weltklima steckt die große uno
konferenz in madrid in einer sackgasse
jetzt geht es darum ob die konferenz
verlängert wird oder ob die 196 staaten
in ihrem anliegen die welt zusammen zu
bringen gescheitert sind und das sind
die knackpunkte die von anfang an für
streit sorgt konkrete finanzzusagen für
länder mit hohen klimaschäden der handel
mit sogenannten klimaschutz zertifikaten
also eine bescheinigung dass man
treibhausgase eingespart hat und
schärfere klimaschutzziele für 2030
besonders gegen den letzten punkt
sträubt sich eine kleine aber
entscheidende gruppe von ländern um die
usa marco jetzt über eine konferenz in
konfrontation
wie können weltweit treibhausgase
reduziert werden wie kann die
erderwärmung gestoppt werden noch immer
wird in madrid über die letzten regeln
zur umsetzung des pariser klimaabkommens
verhandelt mit einem klaren bekenntnis
sollte der weg für nachgebesserte
nationale klimaziele im nächsten jahr
geebnet werden bei den regeln wird
heftig zb über schlupflöcher und doppel
zählungen gestritten die deutsche
delegation übermüdet und leicht genervt
es kann nicht sein dass diejenigen die
bremsen dass die hier das ergebnis
dieser welt klima konferenz entscheiden
hier sind ganz viele die verstanden
haben was die wissenschaft und sagt die
wissen dass man was tun muss am letzten
tag von harmonie keine spur
mit viel klein-klein brasilien wehrt
sich das im abschlusstext eine studie
genannt werden soll die das abholzen des
regenwaldes verurteilt die usa lehnen
gleich bündelweise formulierungen ab
beobachter sind empört die länder die
bremsen die usa australien oder
brasilien haben sehr starke fossile
industrien kohle öl
ein gas- und die machen starken druck
und haben auch sorge was das für sie
bedeutet
am ort ich bin wütend und extrem
enttäuscht das ist die schlimmste kopf
die ich je mitgemacht habe
so viel ist wohl sicher das wird auch
heute wieder spät werden auf der
klimakonferenz in madrid und volker
angres aus unserer umwelt redaktion bot
das ganze in madrid volker guten abend
gibt es denn jetzt doch noch irgendwie
einen lösungsweg
naja wenn es den gibt das wird kein
überzeugender sein dass schluss plenum
ist jetzt noch mal auf 22 uhr vertagt
worden also es ist noch redebedarf da
und erfahrungsgemäß wird dann so lange
diskutiert werden kompromisse
geschlossen dass dann das schlusspapier
sehr sehr schwach sein wird zum beispiel
auch das so genannte regelbuch was schon
letztes jahr in kattowitz zustande
kommen sollte über die technischen
verabredungen der klimakonferenz auch
das ist noch nicht mal geschafft also es
wird wenn überhaupt ein sehr schwaches
ergebnis sein
und dann gucken wir mal aufs große bild
wenn das jetzt in madrid scheitern
sollte welche auswirkungen hat das auf
unser klima na ja es hat vor allen
dingen auswirkungen auf die nächste
klimakonferenz denn diese konferenz in
madrid sollte ja so eine art startrampe
sein es sollte alles akkurat vorbereitet
sein damit man nächstes jahr dann
wirklich in die steigerung der
klimaschutzziele einsteigen kann genauso
ist es ja in paris abkommen verabredet
alle fünf jahre müssen die länder bilanz
ziehen und sagen ja wir müssen noch mehr
tun
die eu hat das ja mit dem 2050
treibhausgas neutral zu sein jetzt
angeschoben das ist jetzt wieder
gefährdet es wird schwieriger werden
also diese klimakonferenz von madrid ist
keine gute steilvorlage für glasgow im
nächsten jahr sagt volker angres
herzlichen dank und den aktuellen stand
zur klimakonferenz die bekommen sie
natürlich jederzeit online bei uns
zusammen mit einer übersicht zu den
großen streitthemen alles auf heute de
oder in der heute app und jetzt in die
deutsche innenpolitik die nach lösungen
sucht um den mangel an fachkräften zu
beheben bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel hat jetzt dafür geworben gezielt
arbeitnehmer auch von außerhalb der eu
anzuwerben
ohne qualifizierte arbeitnehmer könnten
firmen abwandern warnte merkel
laut medienberichten will sich die
regierung künftig um fachkräfte etwa aus
mexiko brasilien und indien bemühen
gewerkschaften und arbeitgeber forderten
die regierung müsse auch mehr tun um
fachkräfte hier bei uns auszubilden
stellen auch brötchen kaufen oder ein
bier bestellen bislang ging das ohne
extra kassenbon und das soll sich jetzt
aber ändern ab januar gilt auch für
kleinste beträge bei uns eine
kassenzettel pflicht damit will die
bundesregierung den steuerbetrug
bekämpfen viel kritik gibt es dafür von
den händlern zu viel aufwand und zu viel
müll supermarktketten rechnen mit
zusätzlichen kassenbons in einer länge
von mehreren hunderttausend kilometer
jedes jahr zettelchen die meist nicht
recycelbar sind und so direkt im müll
landen jetzt sieht auch der
bundeswirtschaftsminister probleme und
fordert auf den letzten metern dass die
kassenzettel pflicht gestoppt wird
byrd benthin berichtet bei jedem
brötchenkauf ein kassenbon so will es
die beleg ausgabe pflicht die ab januar
in kraft tritt auch wenn kunden den
zettel gar nicht wollen
total überflüssig ich habe kein
interesse
es würde dann in irgendeiner tasche
wieder nur um frieden und hab ich sage
bei den meisten einkäufen vorweg schon
vom grafik wir versuchen gerade ja
verpackungsmüll einwegverpackungen zu
reduzieren oder die biologisch bessere
varianten zu nehmen und genau im zuge
dieser situation bekommen wir jetzt eine
vorschrift die noch viel viel mehr
müller zeugen in einem brief stellt sich
wirtschaftsminister altmaier jetzt gegen
die neue regelung und damit gegen den
finanzminister lieber olaf schreibt er
der bürokratische aufwand sei
beträchtlich und im gesamten handel
werden milliarden zusätzlicher
ausgedruckt und in den allermeisten
fällen direkt im müll landen auch aus
nachhaltigkeits gründen sollte dieser
abfall vermieden werden wir kämpfen an
vielen stellen gegen bürokratie und
deshalb müssen wir sehr vorsichtig sein
wenn wir regelungen machen die man
niemandem erklären kann über die sich
viele
mittelständler erregen und die von den
bürgern auch nicht nachvollzogen werden
die idee hinter der beleg flicht
tricksereien an der kasse verhindern
für jedes geldgeschäft ein nachweis die
spd verteidigt das gesetz es sei ein
wirksames mittel gegen steuerbetrug
ich bin entsetzt dass nur zwei wochen
bevor es in kraft tritt mit seinem
vorschlag kommt wo er drei jahre zeit
hat sich vorzubereiten
das läuft jetzt ist es auch klug
überlegt hat ihr eine breite mehrheit im
bundestag und im bundesrat dafür gegeben
und es wird zeit dass dieses gesetz
kommt ab september 2020 müssen
einzelhändler auch auf
manipulationssichere kassen umrüsten und
falls es keine änderung auf den letzten
drücker mehr gibt gilt im neuen jahr die
bonk licht der britische premierminister
boris johnson hat seinen wahlsieg auch
heute weiter gefeiert mit anhängern im
norden von großbritannien und dabei klar
gemacht dass er gegen eine abspaltung
der schotten ist es wird eine wunderbare
zeiten für großbritannien anbrechen er
werde das land wieder einen sagte
johnson
wahlsiegerin ist aber auch die
schottische regierungschef in nicola
sturgeon sie will jetzt ein neues
referendum über die schottische
unabhängigkeit anschieben um dann mit
schottland in der eu bleiben zu können
johnson müsse das recht der schotten auf
selbstbestimmung respektieren in rom
demonstrieren gerade zehntausende
menschen gegen den rechtspopulismus in
italien speziell den ehemaligen
innenminister matteo salvini und seine
partei lega die großkundgebung ist der
höhepunkt der sogenannten sardinen
bewegung die sich vor vier wochen
spontan gegründet hat und seitdem
enormen zulauf hat die demonstranten
haben sich zum ziel gesetzt
jede veranstaltung der lega mit einer
eigenen zu beantworten
seit jahren versuchen flüchtlinge über
das mittelmeer nach europa zu gelangen
ihre zahl geht mittlerweile stark zurück
und trotzdem sterben jedes jahr immer
noch viele die zahlen soweit überhaupt
bekannt
in diesem jahr sind bislang 1246
menschen im mittelmeer ums leben
gekommen
oder werden vermisst in münchen haben
heute kirchen und seenotretter an das
immer noch alltägliche drama im
mittelmeer erinnert brigitte sei
tausende namen stehen auf der liste mit
der sie die opfer beklagen die auf dem
mittelmeer ums leben gekommen sind
seenotretter wie kapitän reich haben es
immer schwerer sein schiff wurde im
september in italien beschlagnahmt
er kritisiert dass immer mehr
bootsflüchtlinge stadt nach europa
zurück nach libyen gebracht werden wo in
den lagern oft fürchterliche zustände
herrschen
ich habe leute auf den schriften an so
große angst davor dort wieder
hinzukommen dass sie lieber ins meer
springen und tod sind als dorthin zurück
zu müssen
in ihrem gottesdienst ermahnen der
ratsvorsitzende der evangelischen kirche
wettfahrt strom und kardinal marx die
europäer heute diesen zustand nicht
länger hinzunehmen
die staatliche seenotrettung ist
eingestellt worden ersatzlos eingestellt
worden
es kann nicht sein dass wir einfach
zuschauen wie die menschen ertrinken
das an eine grenze des vom christentum
doch geprägten europa menschen umkommen
also das darf nicht sein dass nämlich
ein skandal
die zuständigen eu-kommissare sind
derweil in den mitgliedsländern
unterwegs auf der suche nach einer
lösung
man arbeite unermüdlich an einer
verlässlichen und solidarischen einigung
unterdessen wird die liste der toten
immer länger ihre namen lesen heute
flüchtlinge vor die selbst die fahrt
übers meer gewagt haben obwohl auch sie
wussten wie riskant das ist
also in libya livia leidest du lang und
mitte mehr erleben oder ich habe einfach
die kirchen in deutschland stellen heute
die frage wie viel menschlichkeit europa
im mittelmeer aufbringen will
eine befriedigende antwort ist nicht in
sicht
zwei meldungen aus der welt jetzt in
kürze in neuseeland hat der
vulkanausbruch mittlerweile 15 menschen
ihr leben gekostet
eine weitere person ist an schweren
brandverletzungen gestorben
taucher suchten heute rund um die insel
wight island weiter nach zwei vermissten
dabei setzten sie ihr eigenes leben aufs
spiel weil luft und wasser so giftig
sind auch eine neue eruption können
nicht ausgeschlossen werden
neuseelands aktivster vulkan war am
montag ausgebrochen in krankenhäusern
werden noch fast 30 verletzte behandelt
einige von ihnen sind in einem
kritischen zustand und schwere unwetter
haben den südwesten von frankreich
getroffen an der atlantikküste
erreichten sturmböen
windgeschwindigkeiten von 140 kilometern
pro stunde an manchen messstationen gab
es neue höchstwerte
ein mann kam ums leben als er mit seinem
auto gegen einen umgestürzten baum vor
fünf menschen wurden durch abbrechende
äste verletzt
schwere regenfälle überschwemmten
mehrere orte in 400.000 haushalte brach
die stromversorgung zusammen
jetzt kurz vor weihnachten das ist ein
anderes thema läuft bei vielen ja noch
die suche nach dem perfekten geschenk
und da steht bei vielen kindern ein
eigenes smartphone ganz oben auf der
wunschliste
sie kennen sie ja von zu hause in fast
jeder familie hängen sie am smartphone
doch kinderärzte warnen jetzt wer seinem
kind zu früh ein eigenes smartphone
schenkt macht einen fehler alexander
hettich surfen spielen videos streamen
und auch im unterricht sind smartphones
allgegenwärtig selbst grundschulkinder
hängen auf mehrere stunden täglich am
bildschirm
kinderarzt thomas fischbach hält dafür
verhängnisvoll erfordert eigene
smartphones frühestens ab 11 also früher
unkontrollierte smartphone-nutzung
schade kinder massiv sie werden sondern
durch den input erschlagen und das
äußert sich auch in körperlichen
symptomen unter psychischen symptomen
beispielsweise konzentrationsstörungen
abfall schulische leistungen
schlafprobleme bis hin zur depression
weitere mögliche folgeschäden
kurzsichtigkeit haltungsschäden
mangelnde fitness für kinder von sieben
bis zehn hatten experten maximal 45
minuten am tag für vertretbar
und sie brauchen feste auszeiten von der
digitalen welt fördern kinderärzte
kinder müssten doch in schule und alltag
herangeführt werden an die digitale welt
hält der branchenverband bitkom dagegen
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass sie
selbstbewusst und selbstbestimmt in der
digitalen welt unterwegs sind hier sind
eltern müssen die schulen und hier ist
auch die wirtschaft gefordert
viele eltern zeigen verständnis für die
forderung nach einem handy verbot fragen
sich aber wie soll man es durchsetzen
also ich denke dass es nicht umsetzbar
ist aber es wäre schon toll
die meisten sitzen nur noch gegenüber
meinem smartphone und unterhalten sich
gar nicht mehr ganz verwehren kann man
es den kindern ja nicht aber vor zehn
elf jahren finde ich auch schon
empfehlenswert mit ihrer
verbotsforderung wollen die kinderärzte
eine debatte anstoßen entscheidend sei
dass eltern und schulen die zeit
begrenzen die kinder vorm bildschirm
verbringen
und jetzt so eine traurige nachricht für
alle fans von fernsehserien ganz
besonders gerd baltus ist tot
er galt zeitweise als der
meistbeschäftigte deutsche fernseh
schauspieler sein gesicht kannte jeder
ob es bei derrick oder der alte oder
notruf hafenkante
er spielte immer diese verrückten typen
das hat er selbst mal so gesagt ist ja
wohl das mindeste nach der ganzen
schikane
ich habe mich entschuldigt was wollen
sie mehr das tun sie doch nur weil sie
angst vor den konsequenzen haben
gerd baltus wurde 87 jahre alt und sein
werk bleibt das ist der trost
norbert könig macht jetzt den sport ja
die stillen stars kann ich auch gut
leiden der fc bayern münchen laut starke
stars zum teil heute mal wieder
besonders treffsicher 75.000 zuschauer
sehen robert lewandowskis
bundesliga-treffer 219 und 220 der pole
jetzt gemeinsam mit jupp heynckes
dritter der ewigen torjägerliste dreimal
gar trifft philippe coutinho noch ein
thomas müller tor dazu das heißt unterm
strich 6 2 1 nach 0 zu 1 gegen völlig
überforderte bremer profis auch borussia
dortmund in torlaune 4 0 bei mainz 05
hertha bsc erster sieg für trainer
klinsmann 1 0 gegen freiburg erster 3er
auch für kollege markus gisdol köln 2 0
gegen letztlich neuen leverkusen hat das
aufsteigerduell paderborn union 11
ausführlich im sportstudio düsseldorf
gegen leipzig gestern hoffenheim
augsburg 2 zu vier klappbar und leipzig
werden in welcher reihenfolge auch immer
da vorne bleiben schalke kann die bayern
morgen noch überholen eine vier punkte
lücke gibt es zwischen leverkusen und
hoffenheim union und augsburg mit
perspektive obere tabellenhälfte härter
zwei plätze hoch dafür mainz und werder
je einen runter köln übergibt paderborn
den letzten tabellenplatz
das aktuelle sportstudio um elf mit drei
gästen malaika me hamburger bewährt und
der para sportler des jahres johannes
fluss noch an johannes platz zwölf für
johannes kühn im verfolgungsrennen von
hochfilzen vor arnd peiffer und benedikt
doll die deutschen biathleten laufen
beim sieg des norwegers johannes king
das behindert er auch das deutsche
frauen-quartett mit einer enttäuschenden
denise herrmann erreicht nur platz zwölf
das hat allerdings schon historische
dimensionen
ein tag zum vergessen für die deutschen
biathlon-frauen nach dem schlechtesten
staffel ergebnis der geschichte platz
zwölf
muss der realität ins auge blicken und
das haben wir im vorfeld auch gesagt wir
haben aktuell zwei damen die
international konkurrenzfähig sind das
ist die dennis herrmann und franzi preuß
wenn einer davon ausfällt und die andere
dreimal in die strafrunde geht dann weiß
man wenn man realistisch die sache
betrachtet dass da nicht mehr viel zu
holen ist
denise herrmann die
verfolgungsweltmeisterin wirkt
verunsichert
wir wollten heute einfach zeigen was wir
kennen aber durch müssen und wollen und
besonders gut machen und erschießt sich
dann auch nicht gerade leichter die
trainer sind jetzt gefordert das motto
lautet ruhe bewahren muss den mädels aus
das vertrauen geben dann muss auch hier
wieder ein bisschen sicherheit in die
köpfe reinkriegen eine top-platzierung
in der verfolgung morgen darf man von
den deutschen frauen allerdings nicht
erwarten denn die abstände aus dem
sprint sind zu groß um vorne angreifen
zu können
karl geiger ist mal wieder bester
deutscher im team springen in
klingenthal mit den kollegen
eisenbichler freitag und schmid reicht
es aber nur für platz sechs mehr als 150
punkte hinter tagessieger polen
erfolgserlebnis dagegen auch selber
chance für katharina althaus die olympia
zweite wird mit einem 131 eineinhalb
meter strom im wind bedingt auf 1 durch
reduzierten wettbewerb dritte hinter der
österreicherin hölzl und der slowenin
tina damals butter ist komplett da winkt
noch einmal vielen dank
wenn es in deutschland nicht kalt genug
ist kein problem
willkommen im eislabyrinth in washington
dc
all diese blöcke hier wiegen zusammen 56
tonnen seit gestern sind die eisigen
irrwege für besucher geöffnet
meterhoch schön glänzend da kann jeder
seinen weg suchen und das noch das ganze
wochenende lang und dann hoffentlich
wieder rausfinden das wetter bei uns der
dritte advent morgen bringt windiges und
mildes schauerwetter wo und wann die
sonne scheint das war es katja horneffer
gleich heute journal mit der kollegin
marietta slomka um viertel vor elf heute
morgen sonntag freuen wir uns wieder auf
sie bis dann machen sie es gut und in
allen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren die
höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen am
bosporus in mitteleuropa und in
nordspanien bei zehn grad und dauerfrost
beschränkt sich auf island und regionen
weit nördlich von moskau damit ist klar
mit schneefall ist in der nächsten zeit
nicht zu rechnen denn das nächste
sturmtief wilfried das bringt doch vor
allen dingen regen heran
es braucht morgen über großbritannien
nach dänemark und sein kleiner ableger
erreicht morgen süddeutschland und dann
polen heute nacht regen das bis auf den
nordosten kräftig und oberhalb von 900
meter ist in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen schnee dabei dazu pfeift
der wind vor allen dingen an der küste
und das kann gefährlich glatt seien im
nordosten dort sind die temperaturen so
niedrig dass sich noch glatteis bilden
kann
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen milden siegen gerade an der
ostsee und 13 grad am oberrhein
besonders am vormittag fällt noch regen
mit zwei ausnahmen am alpenrand und auch
im emsland scheint die sonne dazu pfeift
der wind noch stürmisch über den
schwarzwald und über die schwäbische alb
und auch an der nordsee am nachmittag
verlagert sich das stromfeld an die
ostsee der sonnige streifen hier in
norddeutschland wird breiter und
frühlingshaft mild und meist freundlich
geht es in der nächsten woche weiter
schönen abend noch